بعد سبعين عاما داخل برج لندن خرج تاج
القديس ادوارد الى النور ووضع على راس
الملك تشارلز الثالث ليصبح الملك
البريطاني السابعه الذي يضعه على راسه
[موسيقى]
تم تصميم تاج الذي يعد قطعه اثريه مقدسه
للملك تشارلز الثاني عام 1661
واطلق عليه هذا الاسم لانه شبيه بالتاج
الذي حمله الملك والقديس الانجلوس ساكسوني
ادوارد المعترف
اذن
يبدو حقا قديما جدا يبدو من العصور الوسطى
ولكنه من القرن السابع عشر لذا فان تاج
القديس ادوارد هو محور الرموز الملكيه
التي يتم ارتدائها اثناء مراسم التتويج
وهو يشكل المرحله الاخيره من هذه المراسم
ظهور هذا التاج اليوم شكل فرصه
وربما تاريخيه لمن شاهده علنا
ان يعود الى مخبئه في برج لندن بانتظار ان
يخرج مجددا لتتويج ملك بريطاني جديد
لمتابعه
المزيد برامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات